As you undoubtedly have noticed,
most of the chorus has been a sort of have a global focus in mostly focused on
foreign countries with Fairmount on Europe and very little actually on America
now.
Now we've come to the part of the course,
we were going to discuss social issues and those are very country dependent.
What's a,
what's a hot social issue?
Depends on the cultural context.
And so we're going to use that to do American issues.
And what are the,
with respect to reproduction?
Uh,
one of the main,
there was a couple of main issues.
One which is not quite as hot as it as it was a decade ago,
but it's teen sex and teen pregnancy as a both has an ethical moral issue.
And as a practical economic issue about the children of,
of,
of teams,
how are they going to get supported and what does it do to poverty,
uh,
of the mother.
And you have some really good readings,
uh,
on those.
And the other one,
the other topic which will come next after this is abortion and we're gonna
spend two lectures on that.
It's going to be a nice long discussion of that cause that's,
that is really the hot topic.
So today is teen sexuality and teen pregnancy.
And just to start with some data and keep it local.
This is from the Hartford Current,
uh,
November last November of November 19th,
2008 and there's a national,
uh,
risks youth risk behavior survey and that monitors health risks among,
among high school kids,
ninth to 12th graders all over the United States.
So in Connecticut,
a 42.4% of the kids have had sexual intercourse of high school kids and it says
31.8% are sexually active.
I don't know exactly what active means,
but I guess they're continuing.
They,
uh,
there's a few percent that didn't like it or something.
Uh,
but there's quite a lot of both one time,
early sexuality and then a continuing a bout of it.
And as part of a problem that of those that are,
uh,
have had or are sexually active,
37.3% reported that they did not use any kind of protection at the last act of
intercourse.
And therefore they're at great risk for pregnancy.
And that's just real sexual intercourse.
Uh,
I guess as Bill Clinton to find session
and,
uh,
when you go to,
oral sex,
you get another set of numbers and,
uh,
oral sex,
as you may or may not know,
is become the big thing in America.
And one I'm sure that we don't really know the causes of it.
I'm not aware of any real academic literature on that.
But the fear of aids,
there is a perception which is true,
that oral sex is less likely to trend,
not zero likely,
but less likely to transmit aids.
And also because,
uh,
maybe,
I dunno how much you are aware of this,
but during the Bill Clinton trials,
the very conservative prosecutor,
Kenneth Starr was talking about oral sex all the time and everybody in America,
uh,
learned about it.
And then he sort of popularized it and has a,
as is often the case,
uh,
people that want to push society in this direction end up having pushed it in
exactly the opposite direction.
So a oral sex is alive and well in new haven.
And,
uh,
I sometimes teach teachers how to talk in their classes about the kinds of,
the kinds of population issues,
that kind of issues we talked about in the class.
And they give me a lot of information.
So,
uh,
one day I'm talking to these teachers and they say,
oh,
something interesting has happened in the school and the low one of the local
high schools,
uh,
a freshman girl and an older girlfriend rules caught in the stairwell providing
oral sex for a line of boys.
They were staying there waiting,
uh,
of few of them with their pants down and this girl was doing them one after the
other.
The new,
this is a freshman in the local high school.
The new haven register,
uh,
has a headline.
Teens turned to oral sex,
10th grade students.
So that's high school sophomores,
40% of the boys and girls reported they had engaged in oral sex in the last year
and about 25% that they had three or more different oral sex partners in the
previous year.
So,
uh,
sex among teenagers is alive and well as they say.
Now.
Uh,
some of my,
some,
here's your anecdote for today,
a teenager.
So Hartford as you know,
it a very bad,
a very,
a lot of poor people in Hartford,
let's just put it that way.
And uh,
planned parenthood has set up a clinic in the northeast,
part of Hartford were very poor part of Hartford.
And this is from one of the,
the,
the counselors,
they're a teenager,
teenage girl comes into the planned parenthood clinic there and says,
I'm pregnant.
And the counselor says,
oh,
how do you know that?
And she says,
Oh,
I know,
I know that I know exactly when I got pregnant.
Oh,
well I know that if you,
uh,
only if your boyfriend comes only once,
you can't get pregnant,
but on such and such a day.
And she named the date.
We did it twice and I allowed him to come the second time and that's when I got
pregnant.
I know that's when I got pregnant because she was of the belief that one time
can do it,
but two times,
uh,
we'll,
well,
they took the test and indeed she would.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Indeed she,
she took the test in deed,
she was pregnant but she had been pregnant like two months before she thought
she was watching him.
The chief had,
it had a completely wrong,
oh my mother worked in the Health Service for the 70
shell shell.
My mother worked in the National Health Service Corps in the seven days.
I'm in rural Colorado and she get a 12 year old come in who was in labor.
She was pregnant.
Did Not.
Yeah.
So that's,
I don't know that your hurdle that or her mother worked in Colorado and a 12
year old came in in labor and she didn't even know she was,
she was pregnant.
So that's the story.
Colorado,
Hartford,
it's,
it's all around.
Uh,
in 1999 which is sort of the peak of this concern about teenage pregnancy,
450 Hartford teenagers,
uh,
gave birth.
How many completed high school?
332 girls graduated from Hartford city schools in,
in that same here.
So one third more girls became mothers then graduated from high school.
You can imagine this was considered a serious problem.
Now,
what is this,
the,
the social,
the political,
the school response to this problem?
Well,
they're kind of hamstrung and a nurse practitioner at a Hartford School Clinic
said that she's allowed to test and treat students for sexually transmitted
diseases,
but you can do nothing about the possibility of pregnancy.
She may not prescribe birth control or even distribute condoms in the,
in the school.
And there was a proposal in the,
in the city council,
uh,
to allow the schools to distribute condoms.
And it was roundly,
uh,
turned down.
And what is,
why is,
what is the political concern here?
The political concern is what you can see here
that,
that
people who are opposed to,
uh,
providing,
contraception for teenagers and including politics.
This is,
this is a,
an advocacy,
and this is not a,
not an academic sort of thing.
And,
but this is actually true that people believe that even discussing sex,
uh,
will tend to encourage it.
And certainly handing out a birth control,
uh,
will facilitate,
teenagers,
uh,
having sex.
So this is the political,
uh,
this is the,
the opinion,
the kind of attitude that that is opposed to it and why the Hartford school
system and many other school systems can't,
uh,
provide,
contraception.
So,
uh,
of course this gets discussed a lot and uh,
and,
and it's a topic of discussion,
not only for the team,
for the parents,
but for the teenagers.
And one nice quote from Mouritsen Lopez who's a Hartford public school high
school junior,
and she was already a mother,
uh,
and she dismissed this idea saying,
all the girls I know are sexually active,
most started in the sixth or seventh grade,
they're going to do it no matter what.
Now I experienced the same kind of attitude.
Um,
I was again,
teaching the teachers,
sort of teacher training kind of stuff.
And I was new at it and a little naive.
And this was Connecticut teachers all over the state.
And before I started said,
look,
you know,
we're going to discuss some pretty heavy heavy stuff here,
in the sex and everything.
And I don't know how much of this you can talk to your kids about.
They roared with laughter.
And what they all told me was all of our kids,
I,
they,
they exaggerated and I'm sure it wasn't all,
but the way they express it with all of our kids are into sex already.
I can say anything that I want this,
there's nothing that they're going to be shocked by.
Okay.
So,
uh,
some schools can do a decent proper sex education and some schools are not
allowed to do proper sex education.
And the problem with,
even in the schools where it's allowed is that it's often the choice of
teachers.
It can be the health head teacher or something who may be a Jock,
uh,
that has said,
okay,
your job to teach sex education.
It's rarely that a teacher gets to volunteer that they survey all the teachers
and say,
this is a tough,
tough job.
Who wants to do it?
No,
somebody gets assigned to do that.
And then you get that very often,
uh,
the teacher herself may not approve of sex education,
for the children.
She may think it's not a proper topic for a school,
for whatever grade she's supposed to teach it in.
She May,
and I say she had maybe she or he,
the teacher may be uncomfortable talking about sex.
Uh,
may not be well educated on how to handle questions about sex or about
contraception.
May also very likely now be afraid of,
of legal complications or disciplinary actions from the school if they handle it
wrong and they say the wrong thing and parents start objecting,
which certainly happens then it happens in Connecticut and I've been involved in
some of that stuff.
Uh,
parents are parents coming in and screaming and yelling at them or,
or,
uh,
threatening to sue the teacher is happens.
In any case,
most sex education teachers,
as far as one has data which was very skinny.
Uh,
the,
the teaching of this subject is just not coming from person's guts.
They're,
they're fulfilling.
A curriculum was assignment.
It's something that they're assigned to do.
And if in something of this nature,
the teacher is not really,
there's not coming from her from her soul,
then it's,
it's a,
it's a guarantee for an unsuccessful program.
And we've seen things like this before.
Remember when we talked about the family planning program in Pakistan and
Bangladesh?
They started with the diease when,
when it was one country,
one is Pakistan,
and the days where the traditional birth attendants who themselves were not
using contraception,
didn't believe in it,
didn't know anything about it,
and could make more money doing attending births.
So the program was a complete failure until they changed and started hiring
women who themselves were using contraception or several high status and really
approved of it.
And then the program became a great success.
So you have to have consistency.
If you,
if you make a law or try to have a policy,
the people that are supposed to carry out the policy most want to do that.
If they don't really want to do that,
whatever your policy is in any area of activity,
it's not going to work.
Okay?
Okay.
Now,
this doesn't mean that it's necessarily terribly difficult to be effective with
sex education.
Uh,
planned parenthood for instance,
I use them an example because I know about them.
Uh,
they do a lot of uh,
sex education for the schools and often with the school is uncomfortable doing
it or it doesn't have anybody that they think wants to do it or is qualified to
do it.
They will call in a planned parenthood or we're one of a number of other kinds
of organizations.
And planned parenthood has flexibility to hire people.
They don't have licensing and so forth with climate who are really committed to
this kind of thing.
So they did what they call a seminar for high school students.
Uh,
again in Connecticut here I think it was also Hartford and they got a letter
back from one of the students.
Hello,
my name is Kelly and I was in your seminar.
I would like to thank you for making me aware of some of the consequences of sex
because of your seminar.
I got the courage to ask my mother for birth control before something happened
that I would regret for the rest of my life.
I also got the courage to ask my boyfriend to use a condom instead of nothing.
Thank you so much.
You've really honestly changed my life.
I guess when the Info doesn't come from the teacher,
it actually hits home.
Thank you,
Kelly.
Now this is a teenager,
teenagers letter and it's,
it's one anecdote,
so you can't make an awful lot out of it,
but you have to think a little bit.
She says,
uh,
making me aware of some of the consequences of sex.
Well,
you know,
do you think she really didn't know the get pregnant from sex that you can get
diseases?
No.
She all knew that,
that she had missed,
identified what was going on.
I don't,
I doubt I'd be flabbergasted if she didn't,
uh,
know that by the time she's in high school.
What do you think you've been more recently a high school doing all the kids
know that you get pregnant from sex.
Yeah.
And all know they can get an STD from Sachs.
I'm not so sure.
All right man.
Maybe Kelly was,
maybe I'm wrong.
And Kelly Kelly was right.
I don't know.
Um,
but the thing is,
it's all the way it's presented.
It's presented by someone that really cares it and wants to do it.
There's just a whole different atmosphere and,
and,
and kids' minds open up to this kind of thing.
Anyway.
Uh,
America is generally,
uh,
in a mess with respect to sex,
education and sex and generally,
and it's quite different than European countries.
So here is a typical graph that is presented frequently in this shows the number
of children born to teenagers.
This is it.
And again,
at the peak of,
of the problem,
and he has France,
he is Germany,
his Japan,
his Great Britain.
OOPS is United States.
Ah,
perfect.
That was the next question and I'm glad one of you caught it right away.
This isn't,
this is again,
they usually presented like this.
It's an advocacy thing.
It wants to scare you.
It wants to show you how much worse the United States is than everybody else.
But as we just got told,
Nancy has a much larger population than any of these places.
So this is not really a legitimate way of presenting the data.
So of course you dutiful teacher,
uh,
re did it.
And here is when you divide out by population and you see it's not as severe as
the illegitimate graph,
but it's still,
the United States is still more than twice has more than twice the percentage
problem.
Any of us,
it's still serious.
So in fact,
they didn't have to do use the improper data.
They could have used data like this and it's still the PR,
the problem,
uh,
becomes very clear.
So,
uh,
from a lot of studies of these kinds of things,
it turns out countries that have a very liberal attitude toward sexuality have
the lowest teen birth rates,
teen pregnancy rates,
and a place like Netherland,
it's probably in the West under either Denmark or Sweden or Netherlands is
probably the most liberal.
And in those countries it's considered a perfectly normal part of,
of teenage experience.
And the teenagers are ex are expected and encouraged to bring their girlfriend
or boyfriend home.
And,
and,
and sleeping in the same room that is maybe starting to happen in America under
how many,
how many of your parents would allow that?
Phew.
All right,
we're going to,
she's married.
Um,
okay.
So in,
in the Netherlands,
uh,
we,
the US rate is 54 per thousand teens,
about one out of 20 each year.
And Netherlands vigorous seven.
So eight times eight,
nine,
eight times lower.
So it's a,
it's a huge difference depending on the,
the country attitude.
So in academically discussing this,
uh,
things get terribly mixed up.
Uh,
there is a bunch of issues which usually people don't separate out what is teen
pregnancy.
And that's very different than teen or can be different than teen child bearing.
Cause not all of those pregnancies come to borough.
There's teen sex and you have sex,
you might get pregnant and if you get pregnant you might actually have a live
birth.
So there's three different steps and when you're looking at statistics,
uh,
you have to separate those,
the hose and another is,
uh,
the whole idea of out of wedlock births that births born to mothers that are not
married.
And then you could go bind or pregnancies.
You combine those two.
So two out of wedlock teen pregnancies and when you read discussions of this,
try to figure out what their talk,
which of these problems they're talking about,
it's often not made a very clear,
but it's very important to,
to keep it straight and all.
I'll try to
talk about these different things,
uh,
and make it clear.
So when you discuss this,
so,
so one issue is your,
what is,
what is it?
Statistics you're looking at referred to.
And I hope I've always been clear in these slides.
The other,
when you go across nationally,
like to other countries and uh,
it's not always clear what marriage means.
Uh,
so,
uh,
in other culture in,
in the,
in the west and in general,
the United States in particular a marriage is a legal statement and it's an all
or nothing sort of thing.
You either have a marriage certificate and you aren't married or you don't have
a marriage certificate and you're not married.
And if you have one and you get divorced,
then you in principle don't have one anymore.
It's an honor off kind of thing.
Everyone really knows whether they are married or,
or they are not married.
In other cultures.
Marriage is quite variable.
Uh,
it's a stage thing and it may have various steps in the match.
So for instance,
in Nigeria among the Fulani a circle at circumcision,
a boy whose aged seven to 10 at this time is then be trolls to an infant girl.
And sometimes patrolled is translated as married to,
uh,
when the,
when the future has,
but they don't live together when the future husband's father learns from the
girl's parents who are living separately that she has begun menstruation and is,
and then is believed to be capable of childbirth.
The grill then moves into her husband's,
uh,
her future husband's compound.
So there's still patrolled,
she's now mentoring.
So she moves in with the husband.
It's still the future husband and she's treated as a daughter of the husband's
father's household.
She's treated like a sister,
uh,
of the boy,
the boy and girl sleep together.
They have sex in the open and the boy is usually in this culture.
It's,
it's a,
it's a hurting culture.
They sleep outside near the corral to guard the,
the cattle against the Raiders and Wilson,
whatever kind of Predator animals they have there.
And this all done,
of course,
very openly,
but they still have the status of an unmarried youth and a maiden were his
major,
not a virgin anymore,
but she's,
she's a maiden.
When the girl becomes pregnant,
she moves back to her father's household and she stays in there for three wet
seasons and they have wet and dry seasons there.
So it's a geological climatological thing.
And that takes two to two and a half years depending on when,
when,
when they've started and then she returns to the boy and only then are they
considered married.
So there's so many different steps and then they're officially married.
And so using our definition of marriage,
applying to the Fulani since they always had that first child and until it's two
or three when they're not married,
basically all Fulani first births are illegitimate births by our accounting of
it,
among the Dogan people,
which is Mali and Burkina Faso.
A girl doesn't move into her spouse's home until the birth of the second or even
the third child.
Uh,
speaking of that in,
in suite,
I lived in Sweden and we have a guest whose son is in Sweden.
When I was there,
the,
the tradition was building up that you get married on the birth of your second
child.
And she is that,
that's still happening or
her own her own son.
But that's because he's a foreigner
in China.
They have,
uh,
an interesting,
systems in the old days and some places that I don't think I described where
they have child marriage and they married a boy to an older girl and the older
girl then acts as a kind of nanny and takes care of the boy,
uh,
until they grow up.
But they're,
they're,
they're legally married,
but he's,
uh,
he's five years old or something and she takes care of them until he becomes,
she's a surrogate mother until he,
uh,
become sexually mature.
And one of the explanations for the low rate of Chinese fertility within
marriage is that a boys rarely have sexual interest in their sisters.
I mean at least not for long.
And so this kid grows up and this girl,
older girls been taking care of him and by the time they get married,
there's no sexual interest hardly at all.
So the rate of intercourse is very low in the birth rate is very low.
And we,
we talked quite a bit about that
also in traditional China that men can take,
many wives and men can take concubines and they can take slaves.
And the distinction among all these categories is not very clear since marriage
is usually not a government function,
but they go to the local Buddhist shrine and do a variety or shrine and do a
variety of different practices depending on the women.
One of the most common ways.
So the,
the marriage,
the first,
there will be often a first wife,
not necessarily the first,
uh,
woman that's taken into the household for Lou sexual relations with the husband,
but what's called the first wife.
And she will be prominent.
And then there'll be all kinds of,
depending on how rich the person is,
variety of other women.
And apparently one of the frequent things is that this,
the,
the degree of importance of the marriage,
it depends on how public the ceremony was.
If there's a big public ceremony with lots of relatives and neighbors invited,
then it's very clear.
This is a very clear,
this is what we would call him a marriage.
Uh,
other cases a,
a woman has just taken in the middle of the night and brought in the house and
there's never anything public done or what's whatsoever.
And she lives there as well as a sexual partner for the husband.
And you can call it Mary to call it not married.
She lives in the house probably till she dies,
uh,
with that.
So,
uh,
this marriage again,
is not an all or nothing kind of thing.
Uh,
it,
uh,
we'll start out with different levels of status and then during the course of
the marriage,
the status can change.
The husband may become enamored of the wife and live in various ways,
race or status or degrade her status and so forth.
Now in poorer communities,
everywhere you read about this in Brazil and in among poor people in the United
States,
a formal marriage is sort of almost disappeared and it's replaced by various
informal unions.
And in these informal unions where there's no,
uh,
no legal status whatsoever.
No,
the word marriages is just not used.
Uh,
the related,
the state of the relationship between the man and the woman is sort of
negotiated daily.
I mean,
it can,
it can change all the time,
uh,
that it's not,
again,
not a fixed thing,
but very floating kind of relationship.
Even in the United States of,
of course a marriage is not a uniform legal situation.
Each marriage as a state law,
it's not a federal,
you don't get married in a federal situation,
get married in a state situation.
So there's 50 different,
uh,
situations all together.
Then we have a prenuptial agreements which are arranged the financial
relationship between the man and his wife or vice versa.
And so that it can be different in other places,
even more issues than just financial are arranged by private contract.
It's not set by law,
but by private contract between the marrying parties are more likely between the
marrying,
uh,
families.
And so,
uh,
a friend of mine daughter went to a college,
in Egypt going to the American University Cairo.
Uh,
I was going to say fell in love with an Egyptian guy.
I don't know they had sex,
I don't know what they come up or not,
but she,
she got pregnant in the girl decided to get married.
Uh,
the parents were divorced and the girl's father went and have nothing to do with
it.
So there was the mother,
uh,
had to do something about it and she was opposed to marriage,
but the girl didn't listen.
So they're going to go ahead with the marriage.
Now in Egypt at that time,
you have to have a marriage contract and that specifies,
uh,
all kinds of rights that the woman has.
What rights does she have in her children without that specified marriage
contract?
They are totally the husband.
There's any divorce or anything.
The husband gets them.
There's no,
no legal case whatsoever.
What her are her rights to travel.
Can She,
can she traveled by herself?
Can she go abroad?
Can she traveled around Egypt by herself?
What her rights to residents,
what are her rights to child custody and so forth.
So all of this had to be specified and there was no husbands do it.
So guess who played,
uh,
played a Versailles.
I played the role of the,
of the father and,
and help negotiate this thing is very interesting.
And uh,
so each marriage means something different in,
in many places.
And you can see that in the DHS surveys,
the demographic and health surveys that have shown you,
it never uses the word marriage.
It says in union that because marriage is sort of a means,
so many different things are means nothing at all.
Now it's often perceived that a teenage pregnancy and related social problems
are,
are from graphs like that or are either uniquely American,
are more extreme in America.
Uh,
but it's not the case.
for instance,
in Japan of women who were teenagers,
that their first birth,
82% became pregnant before marrying of women age 20 to 24,
58% became pregnant before marrying.
And if all women,
26% became pregnant before marrying.
In other words,
uh,
if a Japanese woman got pregnant before her late twenties,
she was probably unmarried at the time that she got pregnant.
And these numbers are uh,
uh,
well our numbers that have actual have live births.
And as you'll see in the next lecture,
Japan is an extremely high rate of abortion.
So these numbers are way,
these are the women who carry the birth determine probably at least these are
our underestimates by a factor of have to,
because this doesn't take in account,
uh,
abortion.
So I've assigned you reading that,
discusses this issue from a whole variety of perspectives.
And if it's,
I don't have to tell you what it is because you'll,
you'll do the reading.
So a little bit of the biology,
biological background to these issues.
And some of this I don't have to tell you about,
cause you were teenagers yourself very recently.
So several things happen at puberty and they're tremendous physical changes.
You've noticed this,
there are tremendous physiological changes.
I'm sure you've noticed that.
And they're even tremendous emotional changes,
which of course you guys wouldn't know anything about cause you've,
you've been studying too hard,
pay any attention to this.
So evolution,
uh,
has clearly designed to have this incredible eruption of the ability to get
infatuated to form,
loved,
have sexual emotions and all comes on like a ton of bricks at puberty.
This is not by chance.
This is not my culture.
This is straight old mother evolution and doing these things to you.
Um,
and simultaneously with this,
especially on males,
there's an eruption but it's not absent.
And females,
uh,
great eruption of revolt against parental authority.
You know,
you're a little kid,
you whatever mommy says,
more or less when you're a teenager,
no,
go.
This competitiveness,
this aggressiveness as violence onsets at puberty and all of this is to set a
place in the dominance hierarchy.
And of course we are in the west,
well aware of these incredible emotional outbursts.
And there's tons of literature about this,
of which probably most same as Romeo and Juliet.
So anybody taking a Shakespeare class,
how old the Romeo and Juliet supposed to be,
13,
14,
some,
something like that.
And what did their great overpowering love caused them to do?
They killed themselves over it very purposely.
They could not live without the other,
with their partner.
So this emotion is,
is extraordinarily strong,
even stronger than the desire to have life.
Now,
adolescent sexuality is more or less disruptive depending a lot on the culture.
And probably the one most important variable is how much teen sexuality is
allowed that do,
does one have an outlet for these emotions?
If the culture allows an outlet,
uh,
in one a variety of ways,
then it probably easier for the adolescent to accommodate this.
If like our culture in principle,
we're not supposed to have an outlet for this,
then the tensions build up and strange things happen.
So,
um,
different societies handle adolescent sexuality very different.
Uh,
you read the Umayyad story about the Egyptian woman and uh,
that is one way in which traditional societies handled sex.
And you remember her sexual initiation began very early.
It began before puberty,
if you remember that,
uh,
it was introduced with what she perceived to be a fair amount of violence member
on her wedding night.
She had no clue what was going on and the women come and,
and,
and investigate her,
uh,
before the marriage ceremony.
And it must be an extremely,
uh,
scary business.
And even before that,
you know,
the women in Egypt,
all those,
well,
that was only one woman you're read about.
They all had clutter.
Ectomies which again,
he read out there.
So there's a lot of violence involved in teenage sexuality,
a lot of places,
and it's a moderately common,
at least in traditional times,
that marriage and first intercourse precedes puberty in Iran.
For instance,
a few years ago,
Iran raised to legal age of marriage to the age of nine.
I may have mentioned this in a previous lecture and the Conservatives were very
upset about this and they were opposed to this because they considered that that
raising of the marriage age be much too liberal for Iranian society.
And the reason that they chose the age of nine was that Mohammed married his
favorite wife,
his second wife,
Iyisha,
uh,
when she was nine.
But again,
again,
warn you that getting married doesn't necessarily mean the onset of sexual
intercourse.
You don't have any idea of what happened there.
But getting married like the five year old boys and China getting Mac does not.
You don't know what that means with respect to,
uh,
to sex,
just that a contract has been decided upon and at some stage,
uh,
sex will,
will take place between the two.
So with respect to this,
uh,
this,
this bill,
uh,
parliament actually passed it oh,
later on.
And they did raise it to nine.
And then a further bill came in to raise the age from nine to 13,
but that was blocked by the Guardian counsel,
which is the conservative religious body.
Uh,
and they thought that since Mohammed got married at nine,
that you couldn't,
you couldn't do anything different than that.
Now in many parts of the world until very recently,
I have a girl got into her late teens or certainly early twenties,
without being married.
It was considered a disaster that then she was here by 20.
He's much too old and she would never get mad.
She'd be a spinster for the rest
of her life.
And
so these cultures had,
most traditional cultures have various prescriptions,
uh,
against premarital sex,
um,
sex before marriage.
And this has several very important functions.
One is to ensure the paternity.
If,
if you're,
if you're married and you had pregnant,
the society can be pretty sure over at least can assume legally that the father
that you invent,
they know the father and therefore the economic responsibility for the child is
very clear.
That's one of the reasons to have a fixed a fixed legal status of marriage.
Uh,
and back then,
marriage and puberty,
we're essentially the same,
uh,
prepubescent girls.
We're all,
uh,
post pubescent girls.
They got married at puberty and that's it.
So a lot of these languages don't have words that the symmetry maiden in the
sense of a young girl and virgin in the sense of a girl who's not had sex.
And there's a large theological discussion in the Bible when,
you know Mary Virgin Mary was,
was she a maiden or a virgin?
And the language maybe doesn't distinguish between these two kinds of things.
Another,
a prohibition against Fremantle sick since puberty and marriage are often very
tightly tied,
that the prohibition against premarital sex was really intended in many cases to
protect girls from pre pubertal sex.
So what,
what was had originally that that goal deal with pre prebuttal sex,
if you retained the legal aspect of it till the women are much later,
it doesn't anymore have that kind of kind of function.
What's whatsoever.
So,
uh,
teenage,
married,
uh,
teenage child bearing was very common.
Illegitimacy,
uh,
was very common.
So the earliest records we have are from the 16 hundreds and the Chesapeake Bay
colony.
And in way back then,
uh,
guess what fraction of,
women were pregnant when they got married of married women.
What fraction were pregnant?
Make your guest 16 hundreds Chesapeake Bay colony,
what?
30 30%,
which is very much similar to the numbers that we've had until recently.
It's just seems to be almost a constant.
And the,
they have fairly decent records,
uh,
through American history and a lot of other histories and the rates of
premarital pregnancy seem to go up and down.
And this can be large increases in the late 16 hundreds and around 1725,
two of the earliest booms of premarital pregnancy.
And I don't have any idea what the costs of those are,
but you can go to our professor of colonial history and try to find out.
So how are these,
why are these not a social problem,
these premarital pregnancies?
Because what happened then
they got married and those kinds of marriages are cold
shotgun weddings and have you all not heard that word?
Shotgun weddings.
You get pregnant first,
then the in principle though,
the image comes from the,
the girl's father and you can a shotgun say you're gonna man,
my daughter aren't you?
But those are standardly cold shotgun weddings.
And I think I've mentioned to you that if the Mother didn't get married either
because of her and willingness or the guys unwillingness,
then she had a real problem.
Because as I said in the Anglo American tradition,
he was not the family that had responsibility.
The village had responsibility for the young child to,
to both the mother and the child had had a support it.
And for all these villages living on the edge of subsistence,
this was not a,
this is a very big burden.
So,
uh,
I,
I think I mentioned this to the stories of pregnant women being chased from
village to village so that they would not have the child in the village cause
then ever thereafter that child is the responsibility of the village.
Another thing to keep in mind that we talk now a lot about a single parent
families and what a bad problem this is.
It turns out that the prevalence of single parent families has always been very
high.
So in the 17 hundreds,
for instance,
uh,
there's a quote from a history book,
one of the main characteristics of European urban households in the 18th century
was the large proportion that were headed by women in ramps in under the
Alzheimer's gene before the,
in France,
before the French revolution,
one out of four,
uh,
homes,
were headed by women and 15 to 25% of all the towns for which they have a data
in this and
in the u s the prevalence.
So the big divorce boom came in after the fifties in,
in America.
Uh,
but it turns out that the prevalence of single parent households at the end of
the 20th century was almost identical to that at the beginning of the 20th
century.
But what was the difference at the beginning of this?
At the end of the century,
single parent households were caused by
either lack of marriage or divorce,
but at the beginning of the century,
death,
death of one of the parents.
So what has happened is that managers
on average didn't last very long in traditional time because one of the parents
would die.
Death was the death rates were so high.
So they coped with single parent families because of death.
And now people psychologically apparently are not attuned to staying together
for a long time.
So even getting married in the first place.
So now that situation has changed so that now what sort of voluntary single
parent families,
but the numbers are probably didn't have changed very little,
little bit.
Um,
okay.
So it's another one of these things that I've talked about in,
in history where things change from outside of human control,
like whether you're married or not,
where they're going to be a single parent outside of human control is brought
into human control.
It's in some sense into human choice.
Uh,
so what has changed in the modern west with respect to all this and is now
spreading everywhere,
is that children are not supposed to get married as teenagers.
Probably if you had gotten married in high school,
and probably every single one of your parents would have really been very upset
by that,
because in the old and the,
the essence has to do with education.
Then in the old days,
you were a peasant.
You were a farmer and things were done the way they had always been done.
And the little kids starting at age five,
six,
seven,
started going into the fields with his,
his mother,
his father or both of them and,
and watching how the farming is done.
And by the time,
uh,
he was a teenager,
he'd probably learn how you do things because it's done.
Traditionally,
there was no,
no science to it.
There's no pontification,
no arithmetic involvement.
This is the way you did it.
When the moon is at such and such a phase after this,
you start planting and so forth and so on.
And you learn all that.
And so there was no need for the,
and no economic need to have a lot of education.
Now,
of course,
that's turned around completely.
Even farmers definitely do not do things in a traditional manner.
Of course,
a lot of education to be a very efficient farmer.
And so we need a lot of schooling for whatever we do.
And so we're not supposed to get married until our schooling is finished.
And,
uh,
your parents who would not only have been mortified,
if you got married in high school,
but there probably would be mortified if you've got married before you graduated
college.
How many of you think your parents would be very happy if we got married now?
Now how many of you are married?
One,
two,
sorry.
Two of the TA's are married and they're like,
no,
moderately married.
So,
and now mostly I teach a biology majors and we all know when to biology majors
grow up.
Is it when they get their MD or is it when they finish their residency,
that's,
that's the big issue.
And they,
they generally don't get married before that.
Okay.
Now we have to do a little quantification of all of this.
So here is the crux of the problem and this is an 1890,
so murky of course as the onset of the Menzies and presumably more or less the
time of beginning of fertility.
And that was at about 15 years of age.
Now with presumably increase nutrition,
although the reasons they're still somewhat,
uh,
questionable the age America is now 12 and a half.
So this period has been extended forward.
The age at marriage was 22 in 18 of the average age of marriage for women.
This is,
this is for women.
And so the period was still failing between the onset was Emily a of sexual
desire.
And the quote,
legitimate realization of it at marriage was about seven and a half years.
And then very rapidly,
a first birth a would occur.
Now what happens is you go to 1988 men are key,
becomes earlier,
and marriage becomes a lot later.
And now both of these things have expanded even more so that now the period of
time between the onset of adolescents in sexual desires and marriage becomes
longer.
And as time goes on,
this gets longer and longer.
And it's the same story for men.
We don't have good early data on the sperm Marquis,
uh,
but marriage is even later than for women.
So for men,
it's 12 and a half years.
That's a very long period of time in the life cycle of a man,
especially not much less for a woman.
And especially during the fertile years.
A 15 to 40 I like 25 fertile years.
This is a 35 this is half are somewhat less than half of your total fertile
period is pre marital here.
So quantitatively.
That's probably where the social issue comes up.
Wait,
wait.
Before 1890s and nutritional side is men are key and marriage come at the same
time.
There's no,
no real interval there,
so there's not a social problem of what to the search was,
what to do with sexuality in this interval here that in traditional times when
our religions grew up in most of our cultural presuppositions grew up.
There was no period though we're extremely little period between the onset of of
adolescents and marriage.
As time goes on and the need for education increases.
That period between
onset of adolescence and marriage grows longer and longer,
and there becomes this very long social period in which by some social
conventions you're not supposed to have sex of the child.
And it's still a child in a sense,
not supposed to have sex,
but the biology is telling them that yes,
they want it very much.
And societies have had western societies especially,
but the,
the rest of the world is not any different.
Uh,
have had a long,
have had a lot of trouble in,
are still in the middle of having difficulty with deciding what to do with this
peer.
What is the morals,
what are the ethics,
what's the religious attitudes that should take place about sexuality and these
periods.
And this whole lecture basically is this whole problem of,
of teenage sexuality is due to that problem there.
Okay.
Now,
so if you look at,
at the time,
what has happened?
What's the,
what has happened to sexuality in this period?
Well,
what do you think has happened to the frequency of sex among teenagers,
unmarried teenagers or team up?
Oh,
well,
Yep,
that is correct.
Here's,
here's the data.
So this data is not clean.
I,
you'd want to bring the data more up to date,
but we just don't have it.
But here's women,
uh,
starting in 1956 after World War Two,
there's a very conservative period in America,
uh,
where the war was very disruptive to have the big depression in the war.
And people wanted to go back to a traditional way of living a little White House
in the suburbs with the man and wife and a white picket fence around it.
And,
uh,
the fraction of teenage women,
this is teenagers having sex,
was like still a quarter,
uh,
more than a quarter.
So it was,
it was not zero by my name means,
and then as time goes on,
it goes higher and higher and now it's sort of double the rate,
not now.
This is a,
this is a 1980,
late,
late eighties.
So we've progressed another 20,
30 years since then,
and it's just continued to creep up.
This is for females and this is,
uh,
for males showing the same thing.
So yes,
indeed,
sex has increased.
No question about that.
But what do you think has happened to the teen birth rate?
This is really what people don't realize is that during that same period where
the,
the frequency of teen sex was rising,
quite noticeably,
the teen birth rate went from 80 or even 90,
in the middle fifties,
during where that other graph started in the middle of this conservative period.
It was a very high teen birth rate.
And then it's going down and it's continued on down.
It's now down to about this level,
about 40,
uh,
currently.
But this,
these graphs rolled done during this period of peak.
It's being a peak in the,
as a social issue.
This bump here,
we're at Ray's temporarily was significant.
We are going from 50 to 60 or something,
which is a 20% increase,
uh,
in,
teen births.
So no one really knows what that is,
but sort of the presumption it was the,
the,
the Reagan and Bush just say no period where social programs to combat,
uh,
pregnancy,
largely sex education were frowned upon,
were,
were put down,
and the result was an increase.
That's very conjectural.
We really don't have any way of finding out what caused that.
But since that's over,
it's,
it came,
it's come back down and continued to fall every year.
Basically the rate teen pregnancy gets less than than the previous year.
MMM.
So,
but it's still a big problem.
Of course,
I showed you in the first guy,
there's still about a half a million,
uh,
teenage pregnancies,
each year.
And that is in the American context about half what it,
what it used to be.
Um,
but,
uh,
in,
in the world it's,
it's middling.
Uh,
it's more than in Europe and less than in a lot of other countries.
So if you break this down,
uh,
this decline in teen childbearing,
you can average it out.
It's 1% a year,
kind of continually since late 1950.
So the last 50 years,
teenage pregnancy has dropped on average 1% a year,
very,
very consistently and you can break it down and stopped in all 50 states.
If you break it down geographically,
it's croptical all ethnic groups,
you pick your ethnic groups,
the teen pregnancy has fallen and the drop in,
especially during the peak of the crisis,
there was a special worry about poor,
a poor teenagers.
And at that time meant mostly black teenagers.
And the rate of drop of teen pregnancy among black teenagers has been about
twice the rate of drop,
uh,
among whites.
So they,
they've come much closer together.
Uh,
and it's not only a child bearing,
but actual pregnancy rates.
If this is childbearing rates,
if I put a pregnancy rates,
it would look pretty much the same.
Okay.
Now we got a problem here.
So we've said that the rate of teen pregnancy,
something like doubled and the rate of teen,
uh,
sorry,
the rate of teen sexuality somewhat doubled yet the rate of teen childbirth went
in half.
So there's a factor of four that we have to explain,
you know,
right now what we think should have doubled in fact went down by a factor of
two.
So what is,
what is the factor here?
Oh No,
what a teens start to do.
What
they,
what matters.
No,
no marriage.
I'll show you.
Imagine in a minute.
In fact,
I will show you marriage.
Okay,
good.
That's good.
Good point.
This is the marriage rates for different ages and here is women in the prime age
of marriage is marriage rate 1960 marriage disappears.
Madge falls off the face of the cliff.
I'm sorry.
Birth rate.
Yes.
Sorry,
my mistake.
Uh,
the birth rate drops.
Yeah,
sorry.
The very,
the birth rate drops tremendously.
And what happens in the early sixties to cause that
the pill,
the birth control pill,
so this is a pure technological effect and this kind of drop.
We've seen this for China and when Mexico legalized,
uh,
contraception,
you get these drops that,
and this is 15 years,
it goes from 250 down to less than 125.
It drops by a factor of two and 15 years,
enormous strop.
And this is all a technological drop due to the availability of,
of modern contraception and the pill and in particular.
And uh,
uh,
we've seen that kind of,
that means that at this point in time when the birth rate was one out of every
four women,
every year of,
of for lasers,
that's a very,
that's a pretty high rate.
That means that,
I mean the other social indicators don't change so much like the economy or the
amount of female education or anything like that.
Not so rapidly.
So this means that at that time,
that must have been a fairly large desire to stop child bearing,
but there wasn't the technology available.
And so as soon as the technology is available,
whom the birth rate drops now for teenagers,
he was age 15 to 19,
you also get a drop also at the same time,
Fanta.
But it's much more gradual.
And why is that?
That's
a,
the legalization of abortion is probably this blip down down here.
Uh,
uh,
16 yeah,
73 no,
that's later.
That's,
that was 73,
so that's down here.
The fertility drop is 60 contraception gets legalized in 65 and abortion in
[inaudible] 73 so it's too late,
too late for that.
Uh,
but the availability of contraception and the legalization of it.
So in 1960,
uh,
contraception between married people was not legal and it was in 1965 for the
part,
way through this drop that it became legal,
but it was used very heavily then was as in China with the one shop policy.
We've just ramped and ignoring of the law.
Who was the Supreme Court case that that was for?
That was a Connecticut case.
The planned parent of Connecticut did the contraception more did the case that
that made contraception legal for married people.
And it was later that unmarried people got the right to have contraception.
So the birth rate drops,
uh,
for married women.
Uh,
but for teenagers that drops much more slowly.
And that's the,
the trade off between that.
They're having more sex,
so you expect it to go up,
but they're having other,
using contraception.
So it's,
it's going downwards.
These women married women at that age were having sex before this period.
So what you see as all a contraceptive effect,
and there's no increase in sexual frequency to counter balance that.
So this is what you would expect.
Uh,
well this would be,
this is the,
the full contraceptive effect.
This is the contraceptive effect minus the increased sexuality effect.
So,
um,
yeah,
and we know that something like three quarters of sexually active teenagers in
this for a long time,
I use contraception and they're,
and they're amazing.
Not,
not good.
They're not there.
They're not dumb about it at all.
They,
in general used contraception at least as effectively as adults.
And in many,
in several of the studies,
they use contraception more effectively than adults.
And so if you ha,
if contraception hadn't come in at that time,
uh,
you would have seen a tremendous rise in teen pregnancy and teen birth.
Whereas in fact,
you saw a gentle 1% a year of gentle drop in teen births.
MMM.
So,
and,
uh,
cross national studies show quite convincingly that the,
that the drop that,
that the moderation that this drop,
that why white teen pregnancy didn't rise when teen sex rose was due to,
uh,
contraception.
So,
uh,
in Canada,
us,
Sweden,
France,
Great Britain,
the age of sexual debut doesn't change very much when you go across these
countries,
about 40% of the 15 to 17 year olds have already had intercourse and this rises
to 70 to 80% a month,
18 to 19 year olds.
Uh,
in fact,
the u s had a significantly lower percentage of girls who had intercourse in the
past three months.
Then at the year,
this was taking say 59% in the u s and 79% in Sweden.
So we had less sexuality and the other countries,
uh,
and even though we had a lower amount of sexual activity,
the teen pregnancy rate,
the teen birth rate,
the team sexually transmitted disease rates were much higher.
And again,
if you compare the use of contraception in Europe,
it's much better than here.
And that explains all these problems with the sexuality.
Uh,
non use of contraception in the United States,
uh,
was five times as great as that,
a Great Britain and three times as great as that in Sweden.
Uh,
the effect is not concentrated in lower economic groups that uh,
that's somewhat interesting facts.
Almost everything else breaks out by economic groups.
Uh,
contracept views among Tina's doesn't vary that much among different economic
groups.
Okay.
Um,
now,
so,
so what's the problem here?
So we started out that there was,
or still is,
appeared to be a huge problem with teen teen pregnancy and,
but we see that in actual fact the data contradicts that,
that,
uh,
the team brings.
It has been declining rather steadily,
1% a year for the last 50 years.
And now half of what it used to be.
But,
uh,
this is,
there's a whole second we can discuss teenage abortion rates,
but what has happened is the disappearance of shotgun weddings.
So this data is primarily pregnant women this little time.
What?
Oh,
wider age range.
Not,
not teenagers,
but 15 to 29 and what fraction we got married before the birth of their first
child.
So they're pregnant before this graph happens.
Sometime later.
They may or may not get married.
What fraction of them getting married before the birth of their child?
They're pregnant.
The child's born.
Do they get married in between traditional shotgun wedding and here?
Oh No.
Well you can see there it is.
It's getting bad.
You haven't seen it was fairly stable for many years and then boom,
it just falls off.
That's white women.
Here's,
here's a total women.
You can see Hispanic and black woman,
what disappears?
It's not an issue with sexual activity.
It's an issue with marriage that the problem is that marriage drops much faster,
uh,
then then,
then,
then the teenagers or anybody else,
uh,
can cope with.
MMM.
And so what happens in here is the source of the problem that even though the
teen birth rate during this period is declining,
the non-marital teen birth rate is rising.
And that's one of the things that people always,
uh,
don't distinguish between.
And it was this,
the non marital teen birth rate that was making,
making a real social issue was not,
not the total birth rate,
but the unmarried birth rate.
And,
um,
and this,
this was enough of a social problem,
but without the teen use of contraception.
The problem,
remember we,
we thought we should,
we fought,
we should have seen a doubling of teen pregnancy and we saw a halfing,
uh,
cutting in half.
So there's a factor of four difference.
This would have risen four times as fast without teenage use of contraception.
And again,
that's the,
we started with,
that's the big one of the big social issues of should teens be given
contraception.
And I think the data here shows that don't go make any kind of moral statement
or ethical statement,
but that if they don't have it,
melon marital teen birth rate is going to be fantastic.
If the question,
somebody I thought raised their hand,
no.
Okay.
Um,
now,
uh,
you have the reading day,
there's all kinds of,
of programs that are supposed to
do something about teen pregnancy.
And you'll read about this one of these,
these virginity pred pledges,
the abstinence only programs,
uh,
various conservative measures.
And there's now good studies of all these and none of them work.
And,
and the information on that is,
is,
uh,
is in your reading.
Okay.
So here's the story on that.
With this drop in marriage,
and this is all women,
it's not just teen teenagers look at the rise in unmarried birth and it's about
a third of all births are to unmarried women of all ages.
And that's,
that's continued on the slow rise since then.
So this is kind of a,
uh,
a huge sea change
in American child bearing practices.
It's going from almost always within marriage to very heavily have to a very
large fraction outside of marriage and here.
So this is the birth rate,
Ron.
So mostly like older women,
it's rising,
uh,
over 40.
It's,
it's low,
but rising,
uh,
35 30 on,
it's rising,
30 to 34 slightly rising,
uh,
25 to 49 little bit rising.
And the only group that's having a lower birth rate are in the 15.
The 15 to 19 year olds that you can see that their,
their line is definitely sloping down.
So this marriage problem,
uh,
this is uh,
this is the change in birth rates and the only one that that's having a smaller
birth rate are,
are the teenagers.
And this is now the unmarried birthrate.
And here you see again 35 to 39 year old women,
very much increased.
Uh,
again,
the 30 to 34 of the different ages.
All the ages of women have an increasing rate on my birthday except the
teenagers.
Here's the 15 to 17 year olds.
They are,
they are falling down.
And here this dark blue line is 18 to 19 year olds.
So whether it's 15 to 19,
that's the only group in America in which unwed,
uh,
child bearing is going,
going down
rate per thousand.
I don't know if you can see this rate rate per thousand.
So 10,000 2,140 per thousand.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you know if the programs
from 15 to 18 year olds you successful at all?
Or is it,
no,
the data has been,
most of the programs work on younger kids
chat.
Why it's not going up as much as the others
that is in debate?
No,
no.
The,
the,
the abstinence programs.
No,
there's two sets of programs competing when an abstinence type programs,
virginity,
pledges of work and the other sex education programs.
And you have to have a very good study to figure out what's going on for any
particular group of students.
And I put in your reading packet some of the best studies of this.
Here's another interesting sort of factor that if you break a teenage birth
rates out by state in America,
the red states have the 10 highest rates and they are the,
the south in the south belt here.
So the most conservative and most and the ones who are the lowest 10 sites,
it's,
you know,
New England,
New Jersey,
upper Midwest,
the,
uh,
the most conservative and the most religious parts of America are the ones that
have the highest teen birth rate.
But again,
you have to be careful about overinterpreting this data because what you might,
this is they get married young are also,
so a fair amount of this is marital teen birth rate.
And again,
the data isn't,
isn't readily available.
At least I haven't been able to find it on what you're worried about at the or
you think you're worried about the unmarried teen birth rate.
Now a lot of people,
some are married about teen birth rate period because it means people are not
getting it.
The,
the,
the teenagers are not getting education and so forth.
But like most other things that the,
the social practices,
uh,
in the more conservative regions of the country lead to a very lower age of
when,
when people have births.
And that's not,
not surprising at all.
Um,
okay.
Okay.
Now I want to expand this internationally a little bit.
So we've talked about America and here is uh,
the,
the country and this is teenagers and it's who have ever had sex.
Two different columns and one column is male and one column is female.
And I cut off by mistake,
which sex?
It was.
So it was it obvious which sex is which.
Here
the left column you'll notice is consistently larger than the right column.
So it should be pretty easy to figure out which is male,
which is female
males on the left,
and then how many people agree with that?
How many people think it's to be the opposite and why do you think it's going to
be the opposite?
Women are going to get married and have sex,
whereas men and uploading the society might have to wait longer.
Right?
Exactly right.
So here it is.
The first column is indeed women.
So you see now the point is very different considerations come in and this is
all an effect of age at marriage.
And so here is the complete graph as it as it was published.
And notice the fraction of teenage men that are in union,
almost none,
nine number.
We've,
we've talked about that,
that the old man keep the young guys from getting married.
And these about 25% across the countries are in union with men who are older and
therefore they've had more sex than the young males have.
Not had the opportunity to have sex.
So this is part of what I've described before about the power structure and the
money structure that the old man keep the young men in kind of a state of
frustration and the females,
uh,
have sex earlier.
Okay.
Um,
now you can look at different countries and uh,
a lot of people,
again,
this is uh,
this uh,
discussion of sexuality is very often tied in with ideas of religious morals.
And you can look at um,
Ireland.
You can,
you can look at religion could look around the world that countries that are of
different religions and one of the most Catholic countries is Ireland.
And,
um,
more than half of all babies are born to mothers under 25.
So they have a low,
a low age of birth and about half of those are born outside of marriage.
So if half your babies are born before you're 25 and a half of those are
legitimate,
that means that all the babies,
just from the young women having babies,
that's 25% of your total babies are legitimate.
Uh,
when you add in the legitimacy of,
of,
of children born to women over 25,
then it increase that the Irish rate comes to equal or exceed the u s rate of
about one third.
Um,
and if you compare the Irish illegitimacy rate to white American women,
which was in some sense the proper comparison group,
the Irish rates way higher,
about 50% higher,
uh,
than,
than the American rate.
There you go.
The other side,
New Zealand is an old fashioned Protestant country.
You've,
it's,
it has the array retro feeling when you,
when you visited,
she was in the,
you've been,
you've been there.
Yes.
And um,
they,
38% of all births in New Zealand are,
are out of wedlock.
In England.
It's nearly 40% of births.
And uh,
they have the same Rambito third of marriages end in divorce and ever increasing
numbers of people see marriage is just an irrelevant thing and don't,
and don't bother in Japan.
I think I gave you these things.
The 26% of first births are two women who conceive before marriage and uh,
and in Japan.
And I guess I mentioned this before,
they have such a high rate of abortion that you can't tell very much from,
from the actual childbirth rates.
Okay.
We're coming to the end.
We are at the end and there's lots more to say.
Let me tell you one more thing.
So the Pan whole pattern of child bearing is,
is changing address the,
especially in poor communities.
So it's very difficult for poor people to bring up children cause they just have
no money.
And so you look,
what's happening is who actually brings up say largely black children in
America?
Is it the mothers,
the grandmother,
very common pattern.
I don't know if it's the,
it's the,
it's that the grandmothers are bringing up the children and we get upset.
You know,
the white dominant group gets upset by this.
But actually it's a split between the biological act of parenting and the
psychological and economic act of parenting.
The kids get married,
get pregnant quite young,
but they're probably biologically very capable of pregnancy at the ages of which
they get pregnant.
So in,
in some sense from a logical point of view,
getting pregnant in your late teenage may be a biological optimum,
but they are not psychologically prepared to be a parent and they're not
economically prepared to be a parent who is most stable psychologically is
probably the mother's mother,
the grandmother who will be 35 or 40 at a time when you were sort of more or
less emotionally stable.
You haven't gotten into old age yet.
And whatever degree of economic stability you're going to have,
which is never going to be very great,
is strongest at,
at that age.
So in a sense it's a very rational kind of split that you,
that you do in your life cycle.
You do your biological reproduction,
the age where you're most capable of that.
And at a later stage when you're most psychologically and economically capable,
you do,
uh,
your,
your psychological,
economic parenting.
And there's also this.
And because of that,
you know,
there's,
there's been big debates in America about welfare.
Does welfare encourage illegitimate,
uh,
bursts and they go in the public roles.
And this is especially done either openly or covertly,
always referring to poor people in often to minority,
uh,
people who,
if you actually look at the economics,
the amount that women get on welfare is really very small,
whereas the major and not enough to allow you to stay alive and bring up your
child.
Where's the economic sustenance coming from?
It's coming from the grandmother,
the grandmother,
the young girl,
and certainly the baby will often live with the grandmother.
She pays the rent.
She has a job that the welfare is not coming from the government.
That's a small amount.
The welfares coming from the grandmother.
So,
uh,
there is welfare involved,
but it's within the family kind of welfare.
And it's really this system of having the grandmother take care of the kids and
economic is support the kids.
That is what enables a large degree of unwed teen pregnancy in poor and minority
communities.
Okay.
We will from that lecture,
we're going to abortion next time.